well the housing and community secretary
robert generic is with us this morning
good morning to you thank you for
joining us
how did you decide as a government which
tears people would be in
well the scientists advised us that
there were five
tests they include things like the rate
of infection in any particular area
whether it's rising or falling the rate
amongst the over 60s the people who are
most likely to get
seriously unwell and what's going on in
local hospitals
and using those five tests we looked at
all the different local authority areas
in the country and came to a balanced
judgment for each one as to where they
should sit
within the tiers and that's what the
prime minister set out now
which of course subject to the voting
parliament will be coming into effect
next week
how um do places exit lockdown that
we're in a higher
tier thinking particularly of say
liverpool well the the tiered approach
that we had before the new national
measures
was working i think most people would
agree it's the right approach
to take a localized proportionate way
forward rather than trying to have
blanket
lockdowns across the whole of england
but we did learn from it
that the tiers were probably not strong
enough to have the desired effect so
tier one
was having some effect it was slowing
the rate of infection
but it wasn't really bringing it under
control tier two
was flattening the rate of infection but
in many parts of the country that wasn't
clearly bringing it down
and tier three was having an effect in
most parts of the country although not
all but not as much as one might have
wanted to see
so i think if you want the tiered
approach to continue which we certainly
do
you need to be sure that it's going to
work and that it will work in most parts
of the country and so
following the advice of sage and the
chief medical officer
and his team we've designed the tears to
be slightly different to the way they
were
before so that we can have much greater
confidence
that they will succeed and that the
battle should be about
de-escalating from those tears rather
than playing catch-up
and seeing places rise up the tears in
the future
so why can people in tier three i've
just looked i was looking in the paper
this morning
people in tier three can drop their kids
off at school go to primark
do some christmas shopping have a
workout get a haircut
go for a swim but not go to a restaurant
what's the logic behind that well
because these are these are judgments
aren't they
well the judgment call is that we want
to prioritize education
and so taking your kids to school
ensuring that they can stay in
face-to-face
education it's just incredibly important
to us all as parents
as a society we want to ensure that
people can stay and work
although if they can work from home they
are strongly advised to do so
but if you can't as many people clearly
can't if you work in manufacturing
agriculture
food processing then you should and can
continue to go to work
we want to ensure people can get the
essentials of life by going out to
to the shops we think hair and beauty is
very important to people's
mental health and general well-being i
think we'd all agree with that
so there are difficult choices therefore
as to where we can reduce the rate of
infection
and some of those settings particularly
indoors
where you are meeting people in a social
setting
are the sorts of places one would look
sadly to try to
retrench and reduce the rate of
infection that leads us
to the hospitality sector none of us do
this
you know with anything but a heavy heart
because we know how difficult it's been
for all those local business people in
our own areas and neighborhoods
over the course of this year but it is a
way
of reducing the rate of infection
reducing the social contact that we have
with others and therefore protecting
ourselves and the rider community
uh so extra funding then for tiers two
and three
there is funding for them so for the
businesses they have the business grants
the chancellor has announced
in the past we've provided every local
council with
funding for discretionary business
support schemes
and many of those supports have only
been launched in the last two or three
weeks and so there's
enough money available for at least the
coming months to support businesses
the furlough scheme of course continues
to the end of the financial year
by which time let's all hope that we're
in a dramatically
better position that's when we're
approaching easter when the cmo and
others think that
uh the vaccine rollout should really
have taken effect and we can be looking
to
move into better times and then for
local councils which i'm responsible for
there's also further support for them so
we're providing them with
more money so they can invest in local
community testing
targeted testing in particular settings
like care homes
yeah mass testing is all important as we
saw with liverpool which is why it came
down
to all intents and purposes from level
three to uh level two
um how do you decide who gets that
does every local authority have an
opportunity do you have to be in tier
three do you need to apply
if you're andy burnham are you at the
back of the queue no absolutely not ev
every
every local authority is being given
lateral flow tests
to do targeted testing that's as i say
testing say
particular workplaces where there might
be a particular risk
care home schools universities but those
places that are in tier three
now have the opportunity to do the same
as liverpool did which is to do
mass community testing and so we're
asking any local authority in those
places to come to us
uh say if they'd like to be part of that
and then we will provide them
not just with the tests but with the
expertise the support the things we've
learned from
the liverpool experience which as you
say was very successful and with
military support
as well for the logistics and if all of
the country that's in tier 3 wanted to
do it
then we would work on a priority basis
but certainly the councils that have
approached me so far
kirk lees for example in west yorkshire
who said they'd be very interested
we're working with them now at pace to
try to get them the resources
and make a success of it i think it was
one of the sort of arrows in the quiver
of liverpool's success they used this
very effectively
we'd like to see the same happening in
other parts of the country um
how quickly can people come out of their
tears it depends who you talk to
is there a possibility let's use greater
manchester as an example that they can
come out of tier three into tier two
before christmas
it certainly is possible there will be a
review point in
14 days time around the 16th of december
so at that point we advised by the
experts we'll
look at each local authority area in the
country and see whether they should
remain in their existing till where
there's a potential
uh to move down the tiers there are a
number of places which were quite finely
balanced
judgments where they were on the cusp of
different tiers so those are the places
which are perhaps more likely to be in
that position
but we've also got to bear in mind see
some movement then do you i think it's
possible but
to finish my point we've also got to
bear in mind that there will be an
opening
over the christmas period which is
likely to drive some
higher rate of infection as some people
choose to go and meet family and friends
uh for christmas day and the days
surrounding it and so you we have to
bear that in mind
our overall approach is trying to ensure
that the tears
hold the line and that places are in a
process of de-escalation what we don't
want to do is ease up too quickly
and then find that in january we're
having to uh to put tears back in place
again but there's every reason to
believe that uh places could see a
change at
the 16th 17th of december mark of course
you have to get
all of this through parliament and there
are a lot of uh rebels as you know 32
votes against two tellers last time
uh as well um if there may be more this
time not least from uh graham brady who
is the chairman of the backbench 1922
committee as many of my viewers
uh will know um if there are more
and labor votes against you or abstain
you're not going to get the easter
anyway
well look we have a job to do to speak
to and convince our parliamentary
colleagues
it doesn't surprise me that conservative
mps are particularly
concerned about these measures
conservatives by nature
want to support people's individual
freedoms want to support small
businesses
so these measures are things we do with
a really heavy heart none of us
when the prime minister downwards want
to be doing this but we do think a
strong tiered approach which enables a
localized
proportionate way forward is infinitely
better than the alternative
which is to have further national
lockdowns and also the difference
between now and the last time we were
debating measures like this when
there was concern in parliament is that
i think there is now a clear way
forwards there is a clear exit strategy
for the country
we've got ever increasing good news on
the vaccine front both the international
ones and our own
homegrown vaccines as a result of that
the question is
how can we steer the country through the
months remaining
until the vaccine rolls out just taking
this i'll come to the vaccine in a
second if i may i just wanted to just
press
you on that point if you don't manage to
get it through parliament what are you
going to do
well we live in a parliamentary
democracy so so the task is to persuade
our parliamentary
parliamentary colleagues well we if we
don't have the votes in parliament then
you you can't implement the policy
that's the way our system
works but we will be uh well we will be
working with our parliamentary
colleagues to try to persuade them
you know the virtue of this system and i
think we'll succeed because
by doing this we can keep the virus
under control
whilst we're rolling out the vaccine and
that is the big prize isn't it
ensuring that there isn't another
national lockdown and that there's now
a fairly seamless process towards easter
time
when the country can return to normality
you won't be able to implement these
changes unless you take parliament with
you there's no other alternative
well we've committed to the being a vote
in parliament so that's exactly what
we're going to do
okay um you talked about the vaccine a
bit of concern about the oxford vaccine
this morning not least because of
america wanting other tests and some
confusion about how
effective it is depending on which age
group you're in where are we with that
are we concerned
um i don't think there's any reason to
be unduly concerned i'm not an expert in
in vaccines so you're probably better
off off asking others but we have now
formally written to the uh body that
will
independently assess the veracity and
the safety
of the vaccine to do their work they'll
do that in the
coming days or or weeks as quickly as
they're able to
come to a judgment and then it'll be at
that point that armed with their
approval that we'll be able to start
rolling it out so there's no concern
there's no reason to be concerned
well i haven't heard reasons to be
concerned but we have to let the
independent
evaluation happen now the chief medical
officer last night at the prime
minister's press conference was very
clear
that although he has seen much of the
evidence
the full weight of evidence will now sit
with the independent evaluation who will
do their own analysis
decide whether it's right to move
forward if it is then it will be rolled
out we're pegging
on that vaccine aren't we we really need
it to work you say mentioned it
yesterday you also said that
we shouldn't hug family members at
christmas
will you be hugging your family members
at christmas well we're still deciding
what we're going to do at christmas i've
been talking to my
parents who one of whom is in his 80s my
mum's a bit younger both have been
shielding at different times
and we're going to make a judgment in
the coming weeks as to what we want to
do
and i think that's what families across
the country will be doing there are
rules now
you know we're very pleased we've been
able to agree across united kingdom
uh legal framework but that's just the
baseline isn't it
each individual family will be weighing
up uh is this the right thing
for you and your family based on your
own circumstances
are you willing to take the you know the
modest risk that's involved
in order to bring family together and
there are lots of different options from
the whole family coming together you
know at home to perhaps
meeting up for lunch with the windows
open or going out for a walk on
christmas day
so there are different options available
and families who have to use their own
personal judgment either way the dogs
involved
absolutely you saw him with uh mr sooner
yesterday under pressure
you bought a dog during lockdown yep i
well just before lockdown actually i
know i i bowed to pressure from my kids
just before so uh perhaps rishi will
follow
so you think you would tell him to get
one i've definitely already recommended
we've both got three daughters and so
i've already recommended to his
daughters that they get one
okay it's great to talk to you thanks so
much